I know
Isaac couldn't come you wanna see Isaac
yeah I need me to grab one more bag he's
like he's trying to play pool we
surprise you are you happy as a team are
we too long I know this these big boys
Wow
Eden we were trying to surprise you
it was so cute so Jenny was like Eden
wants to see Isaac so bad all right
careful with the door okay let's open
the door hi go
you turn down cool down but you see hi
the I be shy I knew the minute you guys
don't you know saw him you can act like
that again I guess someone didn't come I
loved his surprise look though cuz he
was like Florida Florida Wildlife we
have a few hours to spend with you guys
before we leave let's make one what you
want to do you want to take the camera
know that your dream you want to be a
youtuber maybe yeah oh yeah oh you so
big oh my goodness I can't believe it hi
[Music]
he's like doors it
[Music]
[Music]
all right so Joe lives Casey's dream
life yes where he goes on adventures
with his truck and then he for Aiden
guess you've been right at this time
this is amazing
you're literally living his dream like
one of the biggest reasons why I haven't
been able to get an SUV because our
garage that we have right now you know
it's like right there yeah it's so short
so cool this check is this is a monster
look quick shout out but you could
follow his Instagram hey yo cartel and
then he posts a whole bunch of
off-roading stuff and then like where
are you showing us just oh this uh
fridge we use for a bridge this goes in
the back of the truck that is so badass
I want to see all your gadgets and stuff
- now like you must be in this air
compressor inside the truck so we can
air down there of the stars
what it's part of the truck do you do
all this yourself
good that's the radar use one day one
day oh yeah
yeah exactly and then you're talking
about a trip in September I'm like you
gotta go maybe we can take them out for
two weeks and you can let's go learn to
be men look at all this you went on an
adventure yesterday it was crazy man I
know they're trying to wash it away are
cuz it's like big mud chunks
[Music]
yeah yeah because you used to have a an
avocado Wrangler right schooling me
that's what you guys named it you need
your jeeps like it's like a jeep thing
you need oh so cute like you just
usually like if you name a jeep you just
put it like uh you see where I had the
Yoda cartel my Instagram like you would
make it like put the sticker Oh show up
oh he named it like oh that's cute it
was pretty cool reliability I know yeah
I wasn't the best
this is really cool hey Isaac can write
no no you should definitely do it I'm
gonna doing off-roading stuff together
it really is next time you guys - I was
gonna pick the whole crew out and they
got cannons side by side squats and all
that and who I wanted to take you guys
out but I know that the time just to get
there is about at least an hour and a
half we have to really stay here for
like a good week I know
during summer time can you move up your
trip during summertime school is
important you're trying to get that
honor roll he's bored at school that's
why you're like I'd rather write I know
I really write that out all day huh he
went like that to the teacher he got in
trouble for it I'm like eat it he's like
that was what did she say inappropriate
how was that inappropriate was just
yawning I was like eat it when you do
this it means you're bored yeah you know
she's not doing any emulating you know
like all sleepy and stuff and
[Music]
already with the Libyan fire because
he's got that Bentley on fire I know I'm
learning just to like knock it down a
little bit you know we got too much fire
Oh ever since I got married I had to
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
one bite you're trying to be mad Stoney
finish that in 60 seconds there we go
so Aidan and Isaac are sharing a
hamburger a double-decker cheese and
bacon hamburger Aidan took the liberty
to cut the hamburger itself and it was
the cleanest cut I've ever seen a
six-year-old zoo nice
[Music]
remember in the south so we can't come
to this sound without getting some
barbecue alright so after we had lunch
we came back to my cousin's house and we
loaded up the truck with the mini kid
quad that's yours we're about to go have
an adventure
yeah with Isaac and us and Jenny is
gonna be writing and really I've never
driven oh my god good advice gratis
that's quite the challenge there you get
to do all the stuff on there oh dress
which I still get to write on the truck
sorry so we have a couple hours left
before we need to head over to the
airport we're gonna have an adventure
it's the key with the kids yeah and look
at our comments comment please nice show
your friends look at you guys
youtubers you're more protein and dry
just feels so weird like driving such a
big card
you said you want to be like a dog he's
sticking his head out the window oh nice
you took Isaac's hat look at you big boy
oh yeah you little troublemakers you
guys a pig oh yeah by the way the boys
are back there what are you guys up to
over there
[Music]
only us would we try to squeeze in some
offroading catching our flight best sure
that's true
[Music]
all right just about the ride ATV bag
the kids a TV Thank You learning how to
do it real quick
[Music]
i stalled
[Music]
we're going wait Julian
you know Joyner
[Music]
1 2 3 XO I told me to happy
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh it has been so I'm just
taking this really quick off-roading
trip has like made my adrenaline like
tank full right now or like halfway will
you'll wake right halfway pools Isaac's
doing his final lap and then we're gonna
have to head over to the airport and go
back home or it's all boring and there's
no beam right here is just so cute it's
just too addicting do this all the time
I'm so jealous
[Applause]
oh thank you yeah man we got to make an
entire trip out here because that's two
times we've seen Jenny actually three
times we've seen Jenny since she's lived
in Florida we did do a dig for okay this
is a Disney video though her Channel the
fourth time we've come and visit the
first time was an intentional Miami
let's go visit you and like spend time
with you the second time it was the
playlist time and the third time was
like a layover stop when we were in
Puerto Rico and and now this is another
layover stop because we came for
something else but we're like we need to
come and dedicate a good solid no more
pit stops here yeah yeah we gotta spend
time with our family man I miss I miss
them that's terrible on our part hey but
at least we come and visit them when
we're in Florida because someone doesn't
visit us when briefer they're in
California yeah haha because I you can
be a go like twice and not even hit me
up what is that
I'm heartbroken I'm heartbroken Jenni
yeah we're gonna make it a trip wait a
minute the times I've been going is
because of surgery so I couldn't give
like okay fine I can't hold it against
bet on you surgery I think I was it
this money man here's a I want pretty
fast
oh yes such you look so cool I'm looking
at you clapping for you buddy you say
yeah where we going are we going
okay so we said our goodbyes Jenny and
Axl are taking the truck back home and
we're leaving in this smaller car Joe's
gonna be taking us the airport but as
we're leaving the car got stuck in in
the dirt Isaac and Casey we're trying to
push it that didn't work now they're
trying to figure out another solution I
hope we can make our plate
I hope they listen so they can say yeah
great to actually I hope you miss the
flight
I know me and Jenny we're hugging each
other like for five minutes straight cuz
we couldn't let go
we're like oh no I don't want you to
leave and we're like you're not gonna
cry I'm not gonna cry we're not gonna
cry we're not very far but now this
happened I'm like oh we get to squeeze
extra things I know
yeah that's what you said you and your
mommy think alike
we might miss you it's like no we're
gonna get through this Joe Joe is an
action mode he's like this is the moment
I've been waiting for a heavy truck go
tom we're gonna get this out I know he's
on survival mode right he's on bear
girls motor now we got stuff trying to
get out of the offroad yeah I believe in
you Joe but you know what I won't be mad
if we miss our plate yeah look at this
this is what happens right here look at
that buildup right there no way
[Applause]
that's so cool exactly the entire
experience of the truck that's awesome I
want you to get this truck now yeah
decked out this way yeah I'm on it
no more Telluride over can you tell
right cause I'm gonna go straight for
the Tacoma well I mean hold on wait we
still need a family car oh yeah now we
gotta do our part
no we're gonna miss it I know it's gonna
be expensive that's a lot of money
[Music]
oh oh you can do it
Holly's he got out wait don't look at my
no side note I broke a nail
so this is very annoying oh no it looks
like your wish might come true oh yes no
it's presidency yeah I wanna keep one I
want to stay but then I want to go so I
can watch Disney really dizzy place are
always gonna be there oh nice he's
calling Colorado avocado alright we made
it out looks like we might make their
flight after uh you made it no yeah
you're running the wrong weight and I
think really you're just gonna tire
yourself out you got it Oh what happened
no even get up you're mouthing against
frustrated yeah she gets upset I know
you have to go shower Joe's on hero mode
getting you there
[Music]
[Music]